wedding season is coming up and the
focus is usually on Brides but what
about those Grooms here to give us some
tips when it comes to the groom and
groomsmen is the executive director of
Cora's Bridal Ruthie thaler Carter hi
Ruth how are you I am fine thank you
very nice to be with you all it is a
pleasure to have you on now
let's be honest the Bride is a star But
the Groom is so important how can Cora's
Bridal help us with gifts for the groom
and groomsmen
we have some great ideas in the current
issue in every issue of course among
other things we look for gifts for the
men that reference things guys really
care about so we can give you
suggestions for everything from socks to
watches watch winders belt buckles and
sound systems that have come to you from
Bugatti Lamborghini well an item and
some of the other iconic brands that
most people associate with luxury
vehicles that act realized that they're
available in these other products that's
a really good idea I know if you say
anything with Bugatti my husband would
go crazy does Coral's Bridal have ideas
for the reception too
as well as the gifts for the guys we
have some wonderful ideas for the
reception some of them repeat some of
these iconic brand names but the really
exciting stuff you'll see in the issue
are the cakes we have suggestions and
images for absolutely gorgeous wedding
cakes
everybody's going to enjoy I can attest
to that I'm sitting here next to this
amazing cake and it's got the Bugatti on
it the Lamborghini it looks incredible I
love it now cor with of course Bridal
they have a lot of places that you can
get copies of the magazine where where
can we find it actually we don't have a
lot it's only available through Amazon
it's not on newsstands okay and it's not
subscription it comes out once a year
and if people go to amazon.com and enter
Kohl's bridal Smart Tips they'll get
access to their own issue so many great
piggy it's big thick book yeah that'll
take you a year to read the whole thing
there's so many great tips in it and
it's just a beautiful publication Ruth
thank you so much for joining us today
and thank you to Cora's Bridal smart
tips for sponsoring this segment for
more information like she said give them
a call
314-240-5034 Kendall